oh yeah Goodrich how are you oh great
man that's cool you know what it started
out as my son was you know the son of Al
Leiter and that's cool and I don't know
how he takes it and then all of a sudden
now it's Jack Leiter whose dad is out
later I love it
well you know what Al I mean I was
disappointed to hear that you're
stepping away from doing Yankee games
but then I found out the reason Juan it
couldn't be more happy for you thank you
that best night first of all I had a
ball
you know John Filippelli who runs the
network and working with Michael K and
Paul O'Neill and David Cone and Ken
singleton those guys it was a blast
it really was but truthfully is even as
limited the schedule is you know I want
to see my son play more his senior year
and he's he's viewed highly and I just I
didn't want any series either home at
Yankee Stadium on the road to you know
possibly not allow me to watch and that
was really the driving force behind it
well good for you man good for you
what's your favorite Opening Day memory
from your playing days my favorite
Opening Day memory was 1988 when I got
the call well not the call but I made
the team Dave Righetti came up to me in
Fort Lauderdale and said where you live
in kid and I said Dave I don't know if I
made the team yet this was right before
they announced it never told me and he
said you made it don't worry about it do
you have a place to live I'm like no and
he's like you're living with me so in
1988 Dave Righetti and I in Bergen
County New Jersey I lived with rags and
I'm calling home to my mom and my
friends and I'm like like a little
twelve-year-old girl oh my god Dave
Righetti asked me to like them he was
single I was single amazing we were
roommates but more than anything else
rich and I know you know this you know
with respect to opening days and this is
no slight on the Blue Jays the Mets or
the Marlins or any other franchise in
America there is something a little
different and certainly back then when a
lot of the Yankee greats were still with
us you know with respect to the banners
in the opening day and the parade and
the music and all of the dignitaries it
just it really felt like a national
holiday certainly in New York so I have
to say 1988 my first full year in the
big leagues
Billy Martin was my manager it's right
to call your name run out on the line at
Yankee Stadium the old Yankee Stadium I
mean come on I'm getting goosebumps just
thinking yeah yeah and Bob Sheppard I
mean your name heck yeah Billy wasn't
the one who told you you made the team
Billy Martin didn't was no I was
Righetti huh no so ray this was I kind
of figured I was having a good spring
art Fowler was the pitching coach and no
Billy Billy called me in yeah in Fort
Lauderdale but prior to that probably a
couple days earlier and I know like
Guidry and Righetti and Mattingly and
those guys you know the older guys know
what's going on and that's when rags
asked me where I was staying
that wasn't the official announcement
because Billy then I forget the time he
might have been a day later hmm and and
Billy called me in and told me I made
the team yeah what a thrill that true to
form for a Billy Martin managed team Lou
Piniella was your manager by the end of
the year the 89 was Dallas Dallas and oh
that was a mess during that time huh yes
came in you had a little stump barrel oh
that was that was the the very dark
before the dawn Howie Spira era after
all that and then obviously oh my gosh
well you know that story goes you know
by George with Howie Speier it was a
spiral spear Howie's yeah and you know
the whole wind field thing you know
George had to step aside and that stick
Michael along with Buck Showalter helped
create the core for or keep them that's
right otherwise they'd have been sent
off to Columbus for whatever the canfell
yeah or whoever the Ken Phelps of the
era was right no that was a real deal I
think it was I think it was a very very
a no for Felix for me we had Joe Torre
on the day after mariano became the
first unanimously selected player to the
Baseball Hall of Fame and he told us
that that it was on the table Felix for
mean four from Mariano Rivera that it
was really possible and I'm like wow
don't say that to me ever again so let's
talk about is the here and now then how
do you think Bryce Harper is going to
handle
the Philadelphia heat with his contract
cuz it's it's definitely a different
animal than whatever was going down in
Washington DC for him up to this point
of his career out true good point
Philadelphia New York Boston different
fanbase for sure Philadelphia pretty
pretty harsh at times I would say
putting it mildly somebody who grew up
in New Jersey and is very familiar with
with that
listen I think Brice just just let's
just go Citizens Bank Park I mean he's
that he was the most prolific
devastating hitter in that stadium with
respect to o-p-s and all the all the
numbers so it is a very hitter friendly
park and they're not that bricen easy
cuz when he barrels it he can hit that a
Yellowstone but I think Bryce is
certainly mentally tough enough I think
the fact that he did move on away from
the original team that drafted him and
he was anointed as the next you know
whomever as the number one pick and
leaves high school early etc we know the
story III really think Bryce is gonna
have an outstanding year I do
I think he's got plenty not that he
needs it but plenty of support around
them I mean Reese Hoskins 34 home runs
last year Realmuto is a guy I know he's
kind of hidden with the Marlins the last
few years but he's gonna be really good
genes the girl he does get 200 hits a
year couple McCutchen I certainly don't
think he's over the hill so there's a
lot in that lineup again not that Bryce
needs a protection per se but it's a
much more difficult lineup to navigate
which in hit turn not only will it help
a Bryce Harper and his talent but
everybody in that lineup the Phillies
are gonna be really good this year so it
should which is your team in the
National League is that the Dodgers for
a third straight year do you think what
do you got for me
no I my take is and I did a show with
Mark DeRosa this morning and and Lauren
Shahadah you know of course and Robert
Flores in the morning and I had the
Cardinals huh playing in the World
Series losing to the Brewers listen
Richemont it is so easy or much easier
to identify what we think should be in
the American League right I mean you
could it could roll off your tongue
Boston or Yankees win a division dude
does Tampa hold up enough I think
they're going to be very competitive
I think the central in the American
League is kind of clear almost like in
National League West
it'll be Cleveland but the Minnesota
Twins made an awful lot of ground with
their moves and then the West to me is
going to be Houston again and you know
does Oakland do anything close I think
they'll be it'll be an interesting story
the Angels would be better that is this
it rolls off your tongue for me the
National League if if we were to have
this conversation September I'm going to
say it's going to be something like
Philly either and or Mets Washington
Atlanta or if it was I think Phillies I
think the Phillies are going to win the
when the the East I do but I'm telling
you I said hesitantly and again I think
all four of those teams Braves
Washington Philadelphia Mets the Marlins
gonna be better but I wouldn't be
surprised that the winner of that
division has 87 88 wins they are gonna
thump on each other
the NL Central definitely is a gain some
depth the Cubs will be back brewers are
really good that Cardinals are good high
I don't see the Pirates or Cincinnati
Cincinnati made great they did great
moves they they made some interesting
maneuvers now I mean they're you know
queeg is in Cincinnati for crying out
loud I mean that's yeah you know ii-i'll
tell you I think Sonny gray is gonna
have a really good year I do i watch
them a lot I know you know you watching
the Yankees closely didn't do well in
New York but did really well on the road
I think he you know being back with
Derek Johnson his old pitching coach
from banner belt I like that move on
like 10 Aurora they're going to hit
Cincinnati you know even though they
almost lost 100 games last year that
could be one of the most turnaround
teams that will see in 2019 the NL West
I think by default I say LA because they
can buy and get whatever they need the
the the Kershaw ended up having a good
spring I really like Walker Buehler I'm
not sure I think Colorado is going to be
right in the mix no doubt about it I
don't see San Francisco San Diego be
better but they're not a playoff team
the Arizona Diamondbacks went backwards
so the West is not nearly as interesting
as the NL East they're essential well we
had a lighter here on the Rich Eisen
sure we had Dave Roberts on yesterday
and I you know I pointed out the number
of players significant players
bold face name players that are
jobless right now and asked him if the
Dodgers would be interested in any of
them and he said they're done they're
done right now one would imagine all the
way through to July so what do you what
do you think how uh listen I think
everybody's trying to bottom fish right
now with with respect to some of the
names out there I am really really
surprised how Craig crumbled the Kimbrel
does not have a job out there or a guy
like Dallas Keuchel I don't know if it's
a years issue I don't know if there AAV
but how these guys aren't in a
big-league uniform today it's very very
odd to me how could how could I mean you
talk about the Dodgers right there I
mean Kenley you know let's figure his
you know the hard problems right asked
him I really like Joe Kelly but come on
you talk about in this day and age
especially a sabermetric team like the
Dodgers you couldn't use a Craig Kimbrel
now I know I'm not saying I'm just
throwing out there and I know Kimbrel
deserving and should be a closer
somewhere but that'd be a real nice nice
arm you know the rotation not that they
need another left-hander with Ryu and
Rich Hill but if you can get Keiko and a
one-year deal that that doesn't work for
so many of the playoff teams that are
looking for especially if their rotation
drops off after you know 1 2 3 therefore
5s are pretty weak on some of even the
playoff team this might be an odd way to
question about the Dodgers here with a
young player like Seeger and Muncie and
obviously Bellinger but you know is
there window closing I mean Kershaw is
not even healthy enough to start oh this
season obviously they think they're
they're gonna get him in April but what
do you think about the Dodgers here
disease I don't think the Dodgers ever
has a window that closes I think they're
they're really smart front office I I
think the retooling is really the word I
mean if you remember a couple years ago
what Brian Cashman did when they saw
that they were out of it I'm making some
trades and and bolstering their bullpen
horrible minor leagues in particular
with the Chapman trade and oh boy Andrew
Miller riding the Indians they had a
couple of nice trades that bolster their
their minor leagues I think you might
see that as a little bit of a turnover
but no I don't ever see the Dodgers you
know
saying that the window closes and it's
gonna be like a three to five year with
build-up only because they can go out
and buy the next two member I only
wanted to I you know I know they didn't
do it with Bryce for whatever reason but
you know they can if they want so that
franchise I don't think would ever go
through a a few years where it looks
like they're not trying to win few
minutes left without ladder MLB Network
here on the Rich Eisen show are what's
with the Cubs I mean that's an obviously
an open-ended question but you know I
you just sense some severe
disappointment with the performance of
last year and wondering about their
viability moving forward even though
that they have seemingly everything that
you need what do you make of the Cubs on
opening day 2019
they're gonna be in the mix III think
again the NL Central to me is the
hardest to really handicap because I
believe that like the NL East with four
teams Brewers Cubs Cardinals are going
to be right right there in the mix and
what you they'll be competing for that
wild card as well I just like what the
Brewers did I think the Cubs absolutely
will be in there you need for Kris
Bryant to come back and bounce back and
you know you know better than the 13
home runs that he had last year but the
making of that lineup and even if you
look at their their rotation you know I
think that Jose Quintana I thought they
thought they might get you know a little
better than the for EA are a they up to
Kyle Hendricks who I'd like a lot Cole
Hamels you know is is on his you know
he's older on the older side than the
younger side as well as Jon Lester
Pedro strop as their closer you know I
mean there there are some areas where
you wonder where they're gonna lean on
to try to improve come trade deadline
but this is a team that should have
enough together that that would be a a
certainly a playoff team
you know Baez you know moving over to
short I guess Addison Russell is now a
bench utility guy you know so there
there are some concerns there so last
two questions for you here a long-term
one and then the short-term one the
short-term one first who wins the World
Series this year what do you got for me
I got Houston winning
stand over the Cardinals okay you got
Houston winning and I'm telling you I
say that reluctantly my the National
League if Nationals Phillies Mets
Brewers Cubs Dodgers all of those if you
said they're in yeah yeah I get it
there's just there's more flaws that
make each of those respective teams
really good but no one really shines the
way to me how they stand out of the Red
Sox the Yankees and Houston stand out in
the American League okay and Harper
trout Machado just saw in those monster
decade-plus long contract certainly in
the case of trout we check in ten years
from now the player with the most rings
is o most rings hmm
Harper trout Machado boy buy that kind
of questions dang you I'm gonna go oh
God rich let's go with price okay all
right I throw opt-out so he's there for
thirteen years so the Phil's got to do
it they got to do it they got to do it I
know so I add Arenado to that do you
change your your choice yeah let me give
let me give a Colorado Rockies some love
that could be that could be that could
be one that that steps up okay
and let me add judge to that because
he's going to hit it very soon they're
just they're so good they're so deep
they've got a nice pipeline and now in
the minor leagues that's backing up I
got the Yankees you know they're gonna
get to the ALCS they're gonna you know
whatever I mean it's all crystal ball
stuff right you know they could easily
beat the Astros I think that they're
gonna win the division
well I'll enjoy being on the MLB Network
and it's EC baseball circuit I'm very
happy for hours today 9 8 9 a.m. for 12
hours we got live coverage of opening
day on MLB Network attaboy well done
there is there may be an I in lighter
but you're still a team player thanks
rich
good chat thanks al take care you go
that's out lighter the Rich Eisen show
weekday
at noon eastern on audience